uh you know when i when i thought about  it uh you know last night i could barely  sleep i'm like man i just don't want to  come out and and not be who  uh i know i am to be  uh as a player  and just getting up and down you know my  heart racing and just not being nervous  and touching the basketball again and uh  just the rhythm of the game i missed it  so  uh you know when when i'm coming into  this environment i just i'm really  really looking at just being myself at a  uh you know empathetic level you know  how how is everybody else feeling uh  it's been a while  uh but but now it's just time to turn  the page and this first day is over and  and and we just get back to uh you know  collaborating on on what our goal is and  that's just winning championship so i  don't want to make it too much about me  or or you know what's going on well for  the time that i've been away i'm just  focused on putting the best foot forward  for the team and just being available